so we have some some racecars racing
right here and I have an interesting
question to ask you if we assume that
these cars are making this turn right
over here that all of them are making
this term at a constant speed so a
constant speed constant speed of 100
km/h 100 km/h my interesting question
for you is are these cars accelerating
while they make this turn so is
acceleration happening acceleration and
you might say well gee look my speed was
constant it's not changing if I looked
at the speedometer for the car here if I
looked at the speedometer over here it
won't budge it just stays at 100
kilometres per hour
I don't have any change in speed over
time and so then you might say that you
don't have any acceleration but then you
might be saying well why would Sally
even make this video you know and why
would that question even be interesting
and your second your second suspicion
would be true because these cars
actually are accelerating they actually
are accelerating despite having a
constant speed and you can pause it and
think about that for a second if you
want to but I wanted to point this out
to you because in an example like this
the difference between speed and
velocity starts to matter speed being a
scalar quantity only having a magnitude
and velocity being a vector quantity
have being speed with a direction having
a magnitude and a direction and to think
about let's take a top view of this
thing and then I think you'll become a
little become a little bit clearer the
difference between speed in the end
velocity and why these things are
accelerating so if I were to take a top
view of this racetrack do my best
attempt to draw it so it might look
something like this this is the top view
I could even draw this red and white so
red just to give you the idea so this is
the red and there's some white in
between obviously I'm not drawing as
many dividers as there are in the actual
picture but it gives you an idea of what
I'm actually drawing
then there's some grass out here so
there's some grass over here and then
there's some grass over here and let's
focus on this orange car this red car
right over here so where you say and
this is a top view so it's this is its
path right over here and we're saying it
has a constant speed of 100 kilometres
per hour so if you think about its
velocity if you think about its velocity
the magnitude of its velocity is
constant it is a hundred kilometers per
hour but what is happening to the
direction of the velocity remember
velocity is a vector quantity it has
magnitude and direction so up here at
this one is starting to enter the curve
it's going in this direction and you
tend to show vectors by arrows like this
and what you do is the arrow is going in
the direction of the velocity in this
case and normally you would draw the the
length of the arrow shows what is the
velocity the magnitude of the velocity I
should say so its velocity is constant
so the length of this hour will always
be constant but as we see its direction
changes when it's halfway through the
turn it's not going in that same
direction it is now going in a different
direction and when it comes to the
bottom of the turn it's going in a very
different direction and it'll keep the
direction keeps changing as long as it
is turning and I'm not going to go into
Matthew we're going to wait for the math
on this a little bit later but remember
acceleration is a change in velocity
over time acceleration is equal to a
change in velocity is equal to a change
in velocity over time or we could say
over a change over a change in time and
although the velocities magnitude is
constant here it's Direction is changing
it keeps being it if it had no if there
is no acceleration on it its magnitude
and the direction of its velocity would
be constant and the car would just keep
going would just keep going in that
direction so somehow the car is the
car's direction is changing inward over
and over and over again and so I this is
just kind of a little bit of a trick
question something for you to think
about we're going to we're going to
discuss the math in more detail in
future videos but what's happening here
the cars actually are accelerating and
they're actually accelerating inwards
and that's what's changing in words when
I say in words they're being accelerated
towards the center of the curve they're
being accelerated to the center of the
curve and that's what's allowing their
direction to actually change